ich habe mir von einem fahrraddieb extra
ein fahrrad klauen lassen nur um mit dem
tanken zu spielen
hört sich dumm an war es auch was dabei
alles passiert ist auch die vierte
stelle vom typ gefangen habe und ob ich
im endeffekt geschafft habt das war ja
wieder zu bekommen
fahrt ihr im laufen was hast du
eigentlich vor jetzt also ich habe mir
jacobs parat besorgt das ist dieses
rennrad ein sehr schnelles fahrrad was
ist dem die begünstigen wird schnell von
mir davon zu fahren ich werde mit meinem
bmx abbauen das hat genau einen gang und
ist so groß folgendes wird jetzt
passieren ich werde diese tasche am
fahrrad befestigen dort dieses handy
bringt platzieren was wir die genaue
location des diebels beraten wird falls
ich es nicht schaffe so ohne hilfe
hinter dem her zu fahren also du willst
quasi nicht nur ein fahrrad riskieren
sondern noch ein iphone dazu würde es
umgehen wenn es anders gehen würde aber
das ist jetzt nun mal der fall ich
riskiere jetzt noch ein iphone das ok du
setzt kann sie so knapp 1000 euro aufs
spiel führen video was dir vielleicht
100 euro einbringen ja ok sehr gut wenn
nämlich dabei unterstützt 100 tausend
abonnenten zu erreichen lassen wir gerne
oder denn das ist meint damit die
personen die tasche nicht aufmachen kann
und nicht ab machen kann habe ich mir
noch kabelbinder besorgt die alles
überall befestigen werden die die tasche
auch davor hindert aufgemacht werden
aber sehr gut also wenn man ganz genau
hingucken würde würde man vielleicht
denken dass da irgendwas was schief
läuft das nicht ganz sauber ist aber die
zeit hatten die wir nicht denken ich
muss sagen es aber auch ein leckerbissen
für so einen dieb glaube ich das fahrrad
naja ich glaube auch es lässt sich auf
jeden fall extrem gut verkaufen glaube
ich also jeder student würde für dieses
fahrrad
150 euro ausgeben oder lutschen oder das
ist geisteskrank um was ich mache ich
weiß gar nicht was ich sagen soll es
gibt ein paar verschiedene szenarien wie
es ausgeben kann die person fährt weg
ich rufe ihr hinterher und sie lässt das
fahrrad schmeißt sich in die ecke und
rennt weiter dann ist das so und dann
lasse ich die personen davon ziehen
ich erwische die person mit dem fahrrad
gib mir dass fahrer zurück und ich kann
die person zu einem interview überzeugen
trauen szenario ist eine wichtige person
mit dem fahrrad und sie schlägt mir mein
vrees brett aus dem gesicht und sticht
ihr ein messer in die milch und sticht
mir ein messer in emails schlechteste
option allerletzte und hoffentlich nicht
passieren die option ich verliere das
fahrrad und das iphone
und dieses video hat kein happy end zu
dem zeitpunkt habe ich noch gedacht dass
das wirklich alle optionen sind die so
passieren könnten aber es kamen doch
anders als gedacht das ist auch nicht
mein partner also das ist wirklich jakob
zweirad und ich hab's genommen weiß der
wasserhahn er weiß was davon aber er
hält nicht viel davon bis 7 sehr
unauffällig aus muss ich sagen also
kabelbinder macht den braten
wahrscheinlich auch nicht denke auch
nicht machen wir ne pro hier vorne dran
und dann schaut traurig ließ es nicht ab
damit wie es dem dieb auch einfach
machen das fahren mit zu nehmen weil
hier ein schloss zu knacken am
hellichten tage das lange küste
passieren würde nur nachts passieren
wahrscheinlich genau das bringt uns
nicht wirklich dass die tasche passt
auch so gut zu diesem fahrer bin ich
auch na ja es ist wirklich zu krank
kommt niemals jemand auch habe ich auch
nicht die freunde das fahrrad ist ready
wir haben alles passiert habt hier steht
die kamera mit dem langen bild dahin wo
das fahrrad stehen jetzt müssen wir nur
noch einen geeigneten platz fürs fahrrad
finden und dann heißt es warten bis die
muskeln kommt ist das fahrrad wirklich
mit wird jede so an den glascontainer
oder da wo halt hier eh so sachen liegen
kleinkörper hier das sieht so thrashers
die seen des rats und abgeschossen und
dann tun sie so als wäre es ihr
nehmen sie doch so ganz locker schieben
das so los und so also ich glaube wenn
ich irgendwie so von hinten an so einen
containerdienst oder so ja auch nicht
falsch portes du jetzt vors hinzustehen
eigentlich daran die ampel aber ich
glaube das ist weil das dann steht ja
auch ein weg um genau zu sein die
litfaßsäule einfach ja wie schwer das
ist sich ein fahrrad klauen zu machen so
viel planung
hahahaha lassen wir jetzt das rad klein
und familiär mix hinterher
vielen dank dass mir beim video im
museum sachen auch einem geholfen hat so
wie beim museum alles weg ja genau wie
immer mein gott das war das ist wirklich
krank alter hi mein herz hängt jetzt
schon geisteskranken zu klettern
eigentlich muss oder bmx ready machen
dass du hast ja ja ja ich muss deswegen
ja in die tür stellen oder so und da
vorne man sieht ehrlich nicht also die
kamera ist so gut versteckt ja dass wir
den wild rück schon die ganze zeit dass
mich vielleicht werk ist alter aber das
ist alles am start
ich hoffe wirklich nur dass ich mir
keinen oder keinen stich oder so es muss
jemand sein
kein keim an sich unsere daran wie du
quasi der so denkt bad berka dann steht
da so ein geiles und überlegt so eine
sekunde zu lang
vielen dank übrigens als prinz unsere
standard bei der wir immer unsere zeit
verbringen wenn ihr in köln seit kommt
gerne vorbei ist okay hier sticht ich
lange kamera da vorne steht das fahrrad
es wird wirklich geisteskrank leute da
drüben steht gerade jemand der sich ganz
entspannt um kurth erwartet mal eine
sache noch bevor es weitergeht ich kann
das hier nur so machen weil ich von euch
support werde erstmal vielen vielen dank
für den support in letzter zeit das wie
verrückt über 70 prozent von euch haben
den abo button aber noch nicht gedrückt
und werden nicht benachrichtigt wenn ich
neue videos aus bringe ich kann das hier
nur weitermachen wenn ich support von
euch bekommen und ich würde mich riesig
freuen wenn ihr abo button drückt weil
dann kann ich euch wöchentlich weiterhin
solchen content bringen viel spaß mit
dem video vielen dank und drückt den abo
button mein gott geht vorbei er geht
vorbei zürich wir dachten alle dass das
geklaut wird wir dachten uns alle hat
steht wieder einer dazu eine flasche
bier in der hand also ist so ein betrieb
bisher macht er keine anstalten es sind
zwei stunden vergangen ich sitze hier um
es passiert nichts es ist die reinste
schon ich dachte ist der instant weg
aber anscheinend das sind leute vorbei
gegangen die gesehen haben dass das
fahrrad nicht angeschlossen ist kann
dieser ihre männer die das nicht
mitgenommen haben aber trotzdem schade
für das video weil ich musste die ganze
zeit umsetzen und es passiert nichts das
ist schrecklich
wir haben das gefühl dass an dem spot wo
das fahrrad steht einfach viel zu wenig
leute vorbeigehen bestellen es jetzt ein
paar meter weiter nach vorne da wo viel
mehr leute vorbei gehen dass sie zwar
ein bisschen
offensichtlich aus aber vielleicht
schaffe ich es endlich dass jemand das
fucking fahrrad mitnehmen
alle sowie seit vergangen dass unser
essen gestellt haben und es passiert
nichts
[Musik]
der vertrag genommen überhaupt nicht so
viele bürger sogar vom schaffen
ein alter opa sebastian stein oder so
cloud ja ja also keine frage so das
macht sich besser
okay das tor knapp
da vorne die ersten leute er nimmt der
fahrer mit aber das ist eine mission
warum nach der rast um ihr gott stoppt
er will es anschließend wie das
anschließend glaube ich er steht noch da
durch rolle jetzt einfach mal vorbei und
gucken was er macht genau da vorne ist
er als clown oder willst klar willst du
mein gott erschließt das ab und später
wieder zu holen dann schauen wir doch
mal erst mal mit welchen könnten sie
mein fahrrad wieder abschließen
ist dir ja ja das war mein lied können
ja glatt und nach einer taktik schmidt
ist das aufwiegen kann ich mir ja dass
sie aus wien dingen dass einer nicht
mehr haben möchte für mich sehen dinge
die die leute nicht wahrhaben wollen
bisschen anders aus aber okay danke der
mann der über probiert die story zu
verkaufen das erst anschließen wollte
weil das vorne und hinten platter und er
dachte war es hat schmeißt auch niemand
weg auf der anderen seite hat der krieg
nach alkohol gestanden was halt schon
darauf schließen lässt dass ist jemand
wäre der das geld vom staat brauchen
könnte hier überhaupt keine abstufungen
zwischen dieben oder so machen aber mir
wäre es jetzt unangenehm gewesen in
diesem rentner gleichklang anzubrüllen
über ihn des tores kam vorzuhalten ich
weiß eigentlich war es wichtig gewesen
aber ich habe es einfach so loki
gehalten und damals auch okay
nichtsdestotrotz wollte der mein fahrrad
klauen und hat es ganz smart gemacht
habt weggeschoben auf die andere
straßenseite und hätten wahrscheinlich
abends einfach wiederholt hätte der es
wirklich nur davor schützen wollen das
geklaut wurden er ist einfach da direkt
angeschlossen weil zwei meter entfernt
war ja ein fahrradständer also er wollte
es definitiv clown also wirklich einfach
probiert mir irgendeine dome story zu
erzählen aber ich habe immer noch nicht
das erreicht was ich will ich will eine
kranke verfolgungsjagd und das gerade
war er ein hinterhergeschickt
naja ich denke ich denke auch ich denke
auch mittlerweile ist schon so geist
kann dunkel geworden ihr seht das auf
der kamera natürlich nicht weil ich
immer wieder heller machen aber wir
warten jetzt dreieinhalb stunden oder so
hier mittlerweile zu langweilig hoffen
wir mal dass die dunkelheit dazu
beiträgt dass mehr leute sich trauen
würden so ein fahrrad mitzunehmen
ich hatte mit dem video eigentlich schon
komplett abgeschlossen wir saßen
mittlerweile fünf stunden da doch dann
ging es plötzlich ganz schnell
der film solle nicht immer so
[Musik]
es geht los
anders als jetzt
ok freuen das geht los
liga wo ist er
wo ist der scheiße mann ich habe dann
direkt verloren geht von beiden herren
diesen standort geschickt und wie es
aussieht hat er das in den partner also
zum aachener bayer-gefahren in so ein
tag gewesen
oh mein gott fährt durch den achten
dabei
gebt mir mein rad wieder ja was soll das
hier mein handy schwere die teilnehmer
also ja mit beiden beide nationen tragen
game news herrlichen und ich kam an und
er war nicht allein einverstanden noch
zwei andere und ich waren überlegen sage
ich jetzt irgendwas oder scheiße ich
einfach drauf weil ich dachte ich mache
den job ist kommen dahin
der gibt mir ein schlag und ich bin
wirklich ich habe es gefilmt mit meinen
händen sein fahrrad licht ansteht noch
direkt nebendran wert dass zwei
mitarbeiter abgestellt wo ich hab so
gesagt wird mir sofort mein fahrrad
wieder
dann sagt er so ist ist das ja hier
tasche schon offen handy in der hand und
flugmodus domingo hat das 200 mal in
seinem leben gemacht aber der stadtteil
mit so einem glatzkopf und noch so einem
anderen typen in so komplett tracks
dachte hey soli chor und nicht nur
fahrräder
ich bin komplett in die falsche richtung
gefahren wo ist hier vorne beim aachener
weiher sofort links abgebogen hat sogar
in dem trecker nur so von nur wegen dem
trecker roman ich werde komplett in die
falsche richtung so manches urteil kein
licht der komplex ist den ganzen tag
darauf gewartet dass jemand kommt raus
springt weg weg und ich sehe den zug und
fährt mit dem fahrrad dahin stellt
abspringt drauf und gibt gas
wenn ihr mich dabei unterstützen wollt
dieses jahr noch 100.000 abonnenten zu
knacken und mich dabei unterstützen
wollt dass ich weiter jede woche für
euch so content machen kann dann lasst
mir ein abo da las dem video gefällt mir
da ich habe irgendwann die kommentare
wir sehen uns nächste woche wieder
vielen dank an max und alle die mir
dabei geholfen haben
ihr seid kommt hier vorbei und bringt
irgendwas krank ich bin komplett
geschützt und nicht am puls von 24
jährigen man merkt bevor